hey everybody jimmy pardo here for team
coco i am in timothy elephants that's
not right elephant uh elephant elephant
elephant elephant
dressing room yes dressing room room you
pronounce it not room room room he is
the star of the hit fx show justified of
course remember him from deadwood two of
maybe the greatest shows the history of
television uh timothy how are you i'm
very well thank you very much pleasure
thanks for your help on the name and
more importantly about what this room is
called olefin's dressing room yeah what
are you doing here you dress we dress
and we room you did dead wood for uh
three years three years thirty six three
seasons and it ended kind of just ended
it just ended is there uh thought of
that coming back in any way movie form
no no it's comic strip no no uh
you know what right that hasn't been
discussed until now you wanna you and i
bring this into the table i don't think
you'll be there
yeah i'm not included in my own idea was
it your idea or was it just a question
which i took and ran with it because the
brilliance really is to just is to grab
them it was one of my ideas you can't
just steal this nevertheless you won't
be there okay bottom line i'm out of
this thing all right so this railing
gibbons uh you're a marshal u.s marshal
you shoot guns i'm dead woody you shoot
guns have you done any roles where you
don't shoot guns uh oh uh i was gonna
say i played a dancer once but i haven't
i think you'd be a terrific dancer
thanks all right here's the deal i went
out uh to a local department store today
and i purchased two nerf guns i want the
blue one okay blue is you i'll go with
the alien green i want you to show me
how to look cool shooting a gun let's
aim at this door wait don't aim at me
come on get down oh
ow
see that are you literally experienced
come on let's do this what are we doing
close your eyes no it's gonna be a tough
guy test you want to be cool right it's
gonna be you not flinching getting shot
right in the forehead you have good aim
from here all right ready yeah here we
go no no no no what are you doing i'm
i'm waiting yeah yeah but you've got to
wait and be cool so we're just like this
and you're looking at me like i don't
care yeah go ahead you don't just say
hey
oh oh that was good
you were cool yeah that was fantastic
wait that's gonna hit me in the face no
yeah it's gonna up top you feel pretty
good all right all of a sudden the
tables are turned up ready i'm i'm
waiting i mean look how long is this
it didn't mess up my hair dude of course
okay good uh he's the very handsome and
challenging to be the olive font
wow
[Music]
you